I was gonna say like I feel like you
made a transition everybody has growth
but from being like the Jason Lee who
wasn't as big as Hollywood unlocked and
now your your brand is kind of parallel
to your company
um do you feel like there was like
because you've had some public spats
with artists like you said early on you
would shake the the cage up I mean the
Nikki thing alone is you know um but do
you feel like there was like a an
incident or a moment in which you kind
of decided to move a little differently
in terms of like
stirring up unnecessary [__] see the
thing I really don't feel like I ever
started unnecessary [__] I feel like
everything I've started started or
startup was necessary I'm not gonna let
you bully me I don't care who you are
and I've had moments with everybody I
mean with everybody you could think of I
mean I've had moments with people that
people haven't even seen
um I don't think I've ever done anything
unnecessarily I just have I I just now
choose more strategically how I respond
you know sometimes
ideal stuff with behind the scenes or
whatever
um I'm trying to really live in my
purpose now I'm 45 years old
I'm still very hungry but I'm also very
blessed and have a lot of opportunities
in front of me um and so I think back
about a queen a conversation Queen
Latifah and I had where she said
really focus on building your audience
and then take them on a journey with you
but don't ever abandon them so the
people who love the tea that's what the
Jason Lee podcast is going to be about
big opinions very Unapologetic every
Friday you're gonna kind of like wrap up
the week oh my God very unfiltered yes
but you know less the whole dick [__]
[__] this that I mean just you know
um but but very very blunted um and then
um and very Unapologetic and then I
think the Jason Lee show I want to
interview Michelle Obama I want to talk
to Barack Obama these are people that
are important to me I don't want to
scare people to the extent that they
don't want to talk to me but I also want
to be able to keep it real and ask the
questions people want to know like I
have to ask cardi about the song that
quavo did that involves the lady we have
to ask her about the lawsuit with Tasha
K or nobody else can answer these
questions by the way well they can't
they can get the interview yeah I don't
know I don't know no no this is what's
going to happen Cardi's gonna go to
whatever she does her run there's going
to be a long list from Dwight from
Atlantic and it's going to be like you
can't talk about this you can't talk
about this you can't talk about you're
not getting that list I got the list you
should throw it away she threw it away
wow I got the list long [__] list
that's a lot cardi said nah we doing it
I mean
you're good you're good you're good let
me say this people don't understand the
[__] hard [__] that people that do
this go through what I've said at
Hollywood unlocked I'm not letting the
publicist tell me what I can and can't
ask I'm not letting the manager if you
want my audience if you want my consumer
base if you want to talk to me if you
want me to to make your [__] look good
for my world you can say you don't need
it you're not going to attempt because
they would never do it to Oprah never it
would never tell Oprah you can't talk
about this Oprah gonna sit down and say
Megan or Ellen or any of these [__]
Megan how you thought your black ass was
gonna go over there with them white
folks in London put a crown on and they
weren't gonna look at you as a black
girl girl bye you're never gonna be able
to tell Oprah what you can and can't ask
and so when I look at the culture now
and how how talk is just very much like
let's talk about your album I don't want
to just talk about your [__] album I
want to talk cardi wasn't on a radio run
cardi didn't have anything to promote
she right she just pulled up and when
this list came
I'm not gonna say what I said but I I
didn't cardi called me as soon as I got
the list because I was in the chat
because she knew what I was going to say
and she just it was funny we had a
moment but then she pulled up and she
said ask whatever you want because she
knew that she could trust I was going to
be you're not going to try to set her up
with some gotcha [__] I don't do that
and and the great platforms don't do
that yeah yeah I don't do that but I do
feel like a lot of the platforms that do
do it is because they got to get
something because you ain't you [__]
tell them they can't talk about Jesus
they can't talk about oxygen they can't
talk about water they can't talk about
this table they can't even talk how
about how about you just don't ask me
any questions so you just want me to
talk about your album that's it I'm
never that person and I hate radio runs
when publicist would say
and this is just for example because I
love this person but Gucci Mane has an
album
okay look if I'm number five on that I
ain't gonna know what the [__] to ask
him because I'm not you know that's
where you're gonna that's where you know
he's gonna walk into an interview and
I'm playing Jeezy yeah
to create a conversation or move but I
don't want that no more I want to be
able to authentically interview aguchi
and Akisha and be like yo you guys are
the epitome of black love in hip-hop
where we watch you like I mean she's
told me a story about how was that
interview coming soon I hope so Gucci I
want you and Keisha loves me and I love
her but you know her story of how she
like held him down while he was in
prison and started his Fitness thing
with him and how they got fit together
that's great yeah
uh for you like that list though see
y'all don't know yeah yeah those of you
watching who want to get in this world
just know grind your [__] ass off and
be Unapologetic because that was the one
thing that really pushed me to not give
a [__] because I would call different
people that I knew I helped out when I
was the plug like I knew you when you
couldn't get in a club I knew you when
you wanted to go over there and [__] on
oh boy and I put you with him and now
all of a sudden you're this and that so
now I don't get no love that's why I
started saying like I see the games
y'all gonna play but how about this how
about I just because I'm I'm too in the
business to know what's going on to just
sit silent and be a co-conspirator in
your [__] so why not just put it out
there and force you because if I say
something
and Vanity Fair picks it up you may not
like Urban press or black media and [__]
on us and think we're not important but
now you got to answer the Vanity Fair
vain fair is going to ask you the
question
based on what I said and they're going
to cite me anyway so I still got the
credit so I figured out the way of like
really my [__] the business where
like you don't have to participate in
the relationship but I can still get
your attention